so what is treatment like for someone
that's in that zone I haven't been out
of my house I didn't get the job I
didn't do go to the job interview I
actually haven't even applied for any
jobs I'm you know could just getting by
on whatever savings I had and maybe
start to get some welfare checks because
I'm just freaked out because so what are
you saying to me how do we talk someone
through that
well I mean a lot of it has to do with
um well I know we were talking about
this before recording that um when
somebody is that kind of agitated and in
distress the front part of your brain
the prefrontal cortex which is the part
we use for like weighing pros and cons
and anticipating outcomes and
um kind of making decisions and thinking
things through is almost like not
available it's almost offline you can
think about it like it got knocked
offline because my nervous system is a
wreck so the person really
can't make really good decisions when
they're that
um kind of escalated so treatment will
like undoubtedly no matter what include
helping a person learn skills and
techniques to like calm their like
literally calm their physical body down
it doesn't I always tell people you
don't have to be calm that would be
lovely but you don't have to be calm you
just have to be calm enough for your
brain what are some techniques you're
going to teach somebody it could be like
a deep breathing techniques meditation
grounding physical activity is really
really helpful for a dysregulated body
like walking running jumping you to
swimming yoga whatever physical activity
because it's a it's a physical
manifestation of the anxiety so you got
to get the body to be able to relax
enough
for the brain to come online so now once
the brain is more available now we've
got to go through all that cogn that
cognitive distortion this idea that like
if you don't get this job you're a
horrible person like let's let's talk
about how realistic that is or if you
don't get this job it means that you're
never going to get a job for the rest of
your life well look at that so cognitive
like cognitive behavioral therapy
cognitive techniques will address
some of those
really kind of extreme escalated
thoughts so you need both I mean most
mental health and illness issues are
going to require both but for anxiety
you really need both the physical and
the cognitive